well michael it's not about what you're
doing it's about how you feel inside and
what you feel that you've done and your
accomplishments and what is that mr hand
what is it that you've i don't know why
i started talking like that but
my point is how do you differentiate do
you get frustrated in the thought of
like
oh man this didn't become this or oh
in terms of how successful it is is that
do you feel better when it's more
successful i mean
i don't know i see what you mean um i
mean early on
in my career i had a couple of things
happen that
uh allowed me some perspective as far as
managing expectations so
i hope for the best i plan for the worst
listen i'm doing that now
i have that attitude now finally i go
hey
am 150 000 people listen again this week
great right
if they don't i'm not i'm just doing it
i love it i whatever
there's a few things that are within
your control yeah
and there are some things that aren't
and if you can if you can determine the
difference
and then just focus and just worry
about things that are within your
control it's it's listen i talk about it
like it's easy oh all you got to do is
but
it's not easy and i you know you have to
catch yourself all the time it's a
constant process but
if it's outside of your control let it
go
if it's within your control control
it if you want to do a great job on an
audition
you can't control what they think but
you can control
your part you can control the audition
you can control your perspiration you
can control your
character choices you can control just
be prepared yeah just be prepared man
if it's that important be prepared
that's in your control um
so it's so easy as success goes
how can you not look at your career
and say oh my god how fortunate am i
i mean make a list
of all the actors in the industry and
then just highlight the ones that have
been on a television show
for seven years the list becomes
dramatically shorter
it's not easy so you have already
accomplished something that
it's not impossible to do
and so much of that is outside of your
control you didn't know that today was
going to be therapy for me did you
because this is what the show is a lot
of times it's
it's therapy for me you know that i
think all of us
sometimes i mean i think we're as
culturally i think we are
sort of told hey hey like don't
play it down a little bit just back up a
little bit when you talk about yourself
don't pump yourself up so much nobody
wants to it's bragging
if you talk but it's not bragging
or uh egotistical or selfish in any way
to take inventory of your
accomplishments
what you have done and what you were
able to do and qualities that
don't deny oh i'm not so nice no you
know
how kind you are take an inventory
you are where you are because of the
choices you've made and the person you
are
you are a success and sometimes it's
important that we do
take those inventories and i think
that's what we're doing right now we're
just taking a little inventory